when taking a corner kick you're always
factoring in a few things the way the
opponent defense where the keeper
standing and where you want to put the
ball I'd like to put the ball in the
middle of the half circle that we have
the corner kick I place the ball and
usually look at my target you take a few
steps back and position myself sort of
like between 45 and 90 degree angle that
way when you approach it the swing of
your foot can curve the ball towards the
goal keeper which is what you want a lot
of teams usually put a defender on the
first post and then depending on the
second post that's a kick taker you want
to avoid that guy in the first post
because they're usually the ones to
clear the ball out and create a counter
on you if you don't hit a good pointed
kick when you curve the ball in usually
the ball is going to put him in an
awkward position once you do that your
attackers who are attacking the ball are
going to have an advantage you're always
trying to score very rare occasions you
see the actual kick taker score it has
happened very gifted players do that but
when it does it's magical